[Musique]
elles sont irrésistibles impossible de
la manger qu'une seule et elle ne reste
pas longtemps dans leur cacher la
croustille vraiment un aliment plaisir
d'abord et avant tout est dans la façon
dont les marques se commercialisent
qu'elle communique les emballages sont
créés on est vraiment dans l'univers du
plaisir et de l'attirance le plus
possible les j'aime ça quand ça craque
crunch fixa goût de sa ligne puis un
petit peu grave c'est comme le mélange
de ces trois choses là qui qui nous
rendent si joyeux fous de moi pourquoi
on est conscient mais l'ange magique la
texture le gras et le sel vont faire
danser nos papilles et stimuler
certaines demandes de plaisir
particulière dans le cerveau qui fait en
sorte
en fait on a juste envie d'en manger
encore et encore
la consommation de gras de sel et de
sucre activé en notre cerveau des
hormones qui sont associés au plaisir
dans ces produits là il ya vraiment des
considérations qui sont mises pour
essayer de nous faire perdre le contrôle
depuis les années 60 l'industrie élabore
de nouveaux produits en se basant sur le
modèle du psycho physicien howard
moskowitz c'est la courbe du point de
féliciter le point féliciter c'est le
point à laquelle la saveur de l'aliment
va maximiser le plaisir en bouche en
deçà de ce point là la quantité de sucre
de sel n'est pas suffisante pour plaire
aux consommateurs et au delà de ce point
là bas il ya trop de sel de sucre donc
ça déplaît aux consommateurs donc le
point de féliciter c'est vraiment le la
quantité parfaite d'ingrédients qui veut
maximiser le plaisir en bouche puis
l'industrie c'est très bien que nos
besoins sont limitées mais nos désirs
eux sont illimitées lorsque vous mangez
des aliments sains comme des fruits des
légumes vous allez manger jusqu'à temps
que vous vous êtes donc vous avez des
signaux de satiété qui vont rentrer en
fonction
mais lorsque vous consommez pour
satisfaire vos désirs et ceci est fait à
vialas l'utilisation du sucre du grand
et du sel vous pouvez continuer à
consommer jusqu'à l'infini parce que nos
désirs sont infimes puis on s'en rend
même pas compte
selon me hocine 96 % des foyers
canadiens achètent en moyenne un sac de
croustilles par semaine ce n'est donc
pas un hasard si on leur donne autant d'
espaces dans les allées des pistes mais
bon il ya beaucoup de marques beaucoup
de produits mais ironiquement yapo temps
de compagnie derrière tous le grand
joueur qui domine vraiment notable est
au canada c'est frito lay frito lay qui
est une division de pepsico leurs
marques phares l'aise qu'on connaît très
bien mais frito lay est aussi derrière
les doritos et tostitos le chip lead
sunchips lyss be qui les proposent
et on introduit constamment de nouveaux
produits
mais avant de les mettre dans notre
bouche il faut les mettre dans notre
panier c'est pourquoi les entreprises
font preuve d'une grande créativité pour
leur mise en marché
nous avons classé les marques populaires
en trois catégories
on est en fait ce que j'appellerais nos
classiques je pense de nature sel et
vinaigre ketchup barbecue et une des
stratégies intéressantes dans cette
catégorie là c'est que les fabricants en
parallèle de ces classiques l'homme vont
piquer notre curiosité on continue avec
des nouvelles saveurs et les entreprises
donc le savent qu'il ya un sentiment de
culpabilité qui est associé avec la
consommation de croustilles pour bien
des gens donc depuis des années on nous
propose des variations sur le thème
donc on repart du classico en relève à
pedro on enlève un peu de sel voilà qu
on en offre aussi à base de légumes non
la du plein et de la carotte de la
betterave
oui c'est fait avec la betterave mais
quand on regarde le pourcentage de
lipides en tête à 21 grammes pour 50
grammes puis ici on est à 18 grammes
pour 180 personnes c'est moins gros que
ça par contre ça c'est plus seul et
c'est une expérience gustative qui est
différente c'est intéressant c'est un
autre goût est-ce que c'est plus santé
est-ce que c'est plus nutritifs pois
vraiment ça reste très grand en effet
pour une portion d'une vingtaine de chip
la majorité des produits de notre
analyse contiennent entre 12 et 18
gramme de matière grasse et quand on
parle de 18 le chu autour du quart de
mes besoins quotidiens en matières
grasses dans une portion
enfin la nouvelle tendance les costes et
collation
[Musique]
parce que l'on reparle de fibres on
parle de protéines pour vrai donc allez
regard même certains de ses produits le
sont plus nutritifs et nourrissant que
des cracks lundi je prends cet
exemple-là l'on nous l'écrit clairement
en façade 6 g de protéines 6 grammes de
fibres c'est pas des attributs qu'on
retrouve normalement sur des croustilles
régulière donc c'est très élevé qu est
ce qui fait qu'on a autant de fibres ou
protéine dans ces produits là c'est
vraiment la présence comme ingrédient
principal de légumineuses
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'elles sont
riches en fibres et en protéines que
certaines d'entre elles ne sont pas
grasse est salée elle aussi donc la
plupart sont besançon salées sont bons
ça frotte ça fait cruz le meilleur truc
qu'on répète souvent s'est servi d'une
portion qui scellerait le sort
[Musique]